Bienvenue dans Quantum Computing in Practice. Voici l'épisode 6. Aujourd'hui on va se concentrer sur l'une de mes
applications préférées des ordinateurs quantiques, la simulation de la nature. Dans cet épisode, on va aborder les étapes nécessaires
pour le faire pour n'importe quel problème de dynamique quantique, c'est-à-dire le problème de trouver comment la description d'un
système quantique évolue dans le temps. On le fera d'abord à un niveau général, puis on examinera un exemple précis et on le parcourra
en détail, notamment l'expérience IBM de 2023 qui a démontré l'utilité quantique. Pour une petite motivation au
début, l'une des histoires les plus célèbres que nous dans le domaine du calcul quantique racontons encore et encore,
l'histoire de Richard Feynman donnant une conférence au Caltech en 1959 et fournissant essentiellement
une motivation pour tout le domaine pendant des décennies. Le discours s'appelait « There's plenty of room at the
bottom ». Un titre amusant, mais l'idée de base était qu'il affirmait qu'il restait encore beaucoup de physique riche à
découvrir à l'échelle microscopique.
Or, cette conférence n'a pas été vraiment prise au sérieux avant les années 80, quand la technologie avait beaucoup évolué. Et Feynman
a aussi clarifié et affiné son message au fil du temps. Il est retourné au Caltech dans les années 80 et a présenté un autre article appelé
« Simulating Physics with Computers » où il a dit spécifiquement vouloir parler de la possibilité qu'il existe
une simulation exacte que l'ordinateur fera exactement comme la nature.
être capable de se débarrasser des approximations grossières de ce qui se passe à l'échelle atomique et de les remplacer par des
ordinateurs qui comprennent et exploitent la physique quantique, non pas seulement pour simuler ce que fait la nature, mais pour l'émuler.
Rappelle-toi maintenant ce graphique chronologique que j'ai montré dans un épisode précédent. D'un côté, on avait des problèmes faciles à
résoudre qui ne nécessiteront pas le moindre accélération que le quantique pourrait offrir. Mais de l'autre côté, on a des problèmes qui sont
très difficiles et qui nécessitent des machines quantiques tolérantes aux pannes que l'on n'a pas encore.
Heureusement, on pense qu'il y a pas mal de problèmes de simulation qui se situent ici au milieu, ce qui est la région dans laquelle
on peut actuellement travailler. Et il y a plein de raisons d'être enthousiasmé et intrigué par cette perspective parce que la
simulation de la nature est la base de nombreux domaines d'application passionnants. Pour n'en citer que quelques-uns. Si on pouvait mieux
simuler la nature, on pourrait accélérer la découverte de nouveaux matériaux, créer de meilleurs médicaments et traitements, ou
même explorer la nouvelle physique sous-jacente à la physique des particules ou à la cosmologie. Mais avant que toi, moi ou quiconque puisse tenter de
appliquer le calcul quantique à ces domaines passionnants, il faudra comprendre les étapes de base d'un
flux de travail typique basé sur la simulation.
D'abord, tu voudras identifier un système quantique d'intérêt. Ça t'informera sur le Hamiltonien qui régit son évolution
temporelle et une description pertinente de ses propriétés initiales ou de son état.
Ensuite tu devras trouver une méthode appropriée pour implémenter l'évolution temporelle de cet état. Avec ces ingrédients
en place, les étapes suivantes consistent à réaliser l'expérience réelle.
Celles-ci impliquent généralement l'optimisation de l'implémentation en circuit de l'algorithme d'évolution temporelle, l'exécution du
circuit ou des circuits sur du matériel quantique et le post-traitement des résultats. Ainsi on peut
nommer les étapes de base d'une expérience de simulation comme suit.
Identifier le Hamiltonien du système, l'encodage du Hamiltonien, la préparation de l'état, l'évolution de l'état,
l'optimisation du circuit, l'exécution du circuit et le post-traitement.
Mais ce sont des étapes assez détaillées. Rappelle-toi que les quatre étapes du cadre Qiskit patterns, qui aide
à comprendre comment implémenter une routine dans Qiskit sont le mapping, l'optimisation du circuit, l'exécution du circuit et le
post-traitement. Ces quatre premières étapes sont donc en réalité toutes incluses sous le parapluie du mapping et c'est
pourquoi on a consacré tout un épisode à cette première étape et si tu l'as manqué, retourne voir l'épisode précédent.
Maintenant parcourons d'abord ce que signifient ces étapes avant de plonger dans le code. La première chose de base qu'on doit
faire pour réaliser une expérience de simulation est d'identifier le Hamiltonien qui décrit le système. Parfois,
souvent ils sont bien connus, d'autres fois on doit le construire à partir de la compréhension des contributions énergétiques
de petits sous-ensembles du système complet, comme ici où hi est le Hamiltonien agissant sur l'un des n sous-systèmes de h.
On devra aussi noter si le système est composé de fermions ou de bosons si on traite de particules élémentaires. Ensuite,
on doit encoder le Hamiltonien et le traduire en termes que les ordinateurs quantiques peuvent comprendre. Souvent,
ces Hamiltoniens seront composés de particules élémentaires ou de systèmes de spin. Si on simulait des fermions ou des bosons,
on devra choisir une transformation d'encodage comme celle de Jordan-Wigner ou de Bravyi-Kitaev. Ces transformations
nous diront comment traduire la définition du Hamiltonien écrite en termes des composants originaux, les fermions ou
bosons, en opérateurs de Pauli qui sont facilement convertis en gates sur un ordinateur quantique. Par exemple, la transformation de Jordan-Wigner
définie ici donne un mapping des opérateurs fermioniques vers les opérateurs de Pauli. Si on a déjà affaire
à des systèmes de spin 1/2 qui sont très courants, alors on est bon à part pour d'éventuels coefficients de normalisation
et on n'a pas besoin d'utiliser un schéma d'encodage. Ayant encodé le Hamiltonien souhaité dans l'ensemble de gate de l'ordinateur quantique,
l'étape cruciale suivante est de déterminer l'état quantique initial approprié à partir duquel commencer notre
simulation. Cet état devrait idéalement refléter une signification physique ou une configuration du
système étudié. Par exemple, si on s'intéresse à l'exploration de l'énergie de l'état fondamental d'une molécule, on pourrait
commencer par une approximation de Hartree-Fock ou une autre facilement préparable qui a un chevauchement significatif avec le vrai
état fondamental. Le choix de l'état fondamental initial affecte non seulement la convergence des algorithmes variationnels
comme le VQE, le solveur quantique variationnel, mais aussi la précision et l'efficacité de
l'évolution temporelle ou de l'échantillonnage dans l'estimation de phase quantique. En essence, l'état initial sert de
point de départ pour le calcul, préparant le terrain pour extraire des observables utiles sur le système quantique
qu'on modélise. La préparation d'un état arbitraire à n qubits où ci sont les états de base computationnels et ai est
WEBVTT
le coefficient respectif de chaque état et la condition de normalisation 2 n moins un peut généralement être abordée par
l'initialisation de l'état avec l'opérateur o, l'état de départ serait l'état de base standard tout à zéro souvent écrit
comme ça pour simplification. En général, cela nécessite un nombre exponentiel de gates C not. Souvent on est
intéressé par un état initial spécifique pour le système et sa préparation peut être implémentée avec une quantité raisonnable
de ressources. Les états produits par exemple, dans lesquels les qubits ne sont pas intriqués les uns avec les autres, ne nécessitent que des opérations sur un seul
qubit. On n'a pas encore eu l'occasion de parler de la trotterisation
mais certains d'entre vous la connaissent probablement déjà. En essence, la trotterisation est une méthode pour calculer l'exponentiation matricielle qui
utilise des approximations pour gérer la nature exponentielle des opérateurs non commutatifs. Quand deux opérateurs comme HA
et HB ne commutent pas, on doit employer une astuce ingénieuse et appliquer alternativement les exponentielles correspondantes de
e puissance moins i ha et e puissance moins i hb pour n nombre de
fois. Les opérateurs d'évolution alternants sont appliqués. Je n'irai pas dans la preuve ici, mais je partagerai un lien
vers une belle preuve simple de cet énoncé dans la description. Mais le message principal est celui-ci. L'évolution temporelle est une
partie importante du mapping. La trotterisation décompose une interaction continue en étapes discrètes qui peuvent
être implémentées sur un ordinateur quantique. Après avoir généré le circuit trotterisé, on a enfin terminé l'étape de
mapping. On peut maintenant passer à l'optimisation du circuit.
Pour ce faire, voici ce qui doit être accompli. Il faut un layout de qubits qui mappe les qubits virtuels du
circuit sur les qubits physiques du matériel. C'est nécessaire parce que le matériel peut avoir des topologies particulières
qui restreignent l'interaction directe des qubits physiques. Alors que l'implémentation d'un
circuit quantique suppose souvent la capacité pour n'importe quel qubit d'interagir avec n'importe quel autre qubit. On doit ensuite insérer des
gates swap selon les besoins pour acheminer les interactions entre les qubits qui ne sont pas connectés. On doit traduire les
gates de notre circuit en architecture d'ensemble d'instructions ou instructions ISA qui
peuvent être directement exécutées sur le matériel. On doit ensuite effectuer des optimisations du circuit pour minimiser la
profondeur du circuit et le nombre de gates. Cette étape peut aussi être effectuée sur le circuit virtuel. Le circuit où les qubits
n'ont pas encore été mappés sur une topologie de dispositif. Mais rappelle-toi que la majeure partie de ça est fait automatiquement pour toi dans
Qiskit. On verra exactement comment dans la prochaine section de ce cours. Après l'étape d'optimisation, on est prêt à exécuter
le circuit en utilisant une primitive. Pour la plupart des expériences de simulation, tu t'intéresses à comprendre le changement
de certaines propriétés du système avec le temps. Il est donc probable que tu utiliseras la primitive estimator parce que ça
te permettra de mesurer les valeurs attendues des observables correspondant à des propriétés spécifiques. On va ensuite
configurer les meilleures options pour l'estimator qui peut ajouter des techniques de suppression et d'atténuation des erreurs. Enfin, on va exécuter
l'expérience. La dernière étape est le post-traitement de toutes les données. Ça extrait les valeurs attendues mesurées ou si
tu utilises le sampler, la distribution de probabilité échantillonnée dans la base computationnelle. Si tout ce dont on a besoin
ce sont les valeurs attendues des observables d'intérêt, celles-ci peuvent être directement obtenues à partir de la primitive
estimator à la fois dans leurs valeurs brutes et atténuées par les erreurs. Souvent on utilisera alors les valeurs attendues mesurées
pour d'autres calculs portant sur d'autres quantités d'intérêt qui ne nécessitent pas de calcul quantique et peuvent être
calculées sur un ordinateur classique.
Maintenant on va parcourir un exemple réel tiré d'un article très influent qu'IBM a publié il y a quelques années appelé
« Evidence for the utility of quantum computing before fault tolerance ». Cet article qu'on abrège affectueusement comme
l'article sur l'utilité est devenu un article très influent dans le domaine du calcul quantique presque immédiatement après sa publication.
La thèse générale de l'article est qu'un ordinateur quantique bruité a produit des résultats précis ou des valeurs attendues
en utilisant 127 qubits et 2 880 gates au-delà des capacités du calcul par
force brute qui est la simulation exacte des circuits quantiques exécutés par le matériel. Ce travail était
aussi important parce qu'il a montré qu'un ordinateur quantique pouvait être utilisé pour vérifier ou comparer des résultats avec d'autres
méthodes classiques approximatives pour les simulations quantiques telles que les algorithmes de réseau tensoriel où la solution
n'était pas connue a priori. Ce qui est aussi plutôt cool, c'est que maintenant d'autres personnes utilisant les systèmes quantiques IBM sur
le cloud et Qiskit peuvent dupliquer et vérifier ces résultats eux-mêmes.
Je vais te montrer comment faire exactement ça. Donc pour cet exemple, on va être un peu plus précis sur les
étapes impliquées dans le mapping de ce problème en entrées qui peuvent être comprises par un dispositif quantique. Dans ce cas, on va
simuler la dynamique de l'aimantation totale d'un système de spins magnétiques dipolaires sur un réseau en
présence d'un champ magnétique externe. Le système peut être décrit par un modèle d'Ising avec un champ magnétique transversal.
On modélise ça avec un circuit quantique paramétrisé où les paramètres correspondent à la valeur réglable de
l'interaction spin-spin ou z et la force du champ magnétique X. Maintenant,
cette série s'appelle Quantum Computing in Practice. On va donc aussi discuter des procédures dans cette expérience
qu'on va implémenter pour rendre les résultats aussi bons que possible. On va donc ensuite discuter de comment supprimer les
mauvais qubits ou les qubits avec de faibles fidélités de gate ou des temps de décohérence qui pourraient affecter drastiquement les
résultats expérimentaux. Ces mauvais qubits peuvent survenir à cause d'une mauvaise calibration préalable
ou de systèmes à deux niveaux interagissant avec le qubit. Supprimer certains qubits de la topologie native du matériel correspond à
considérer un système sur un réseau décrit par la topologie résultante. On va aussi discuter de la création du
circuit quantique paramétrisé qui implémente l'évolution temporelle du système via la trotterisation.
À cette fin, il sera important d'identifier les couches d'intrication qui sont une partie critique pour la principale technique d'atténuation des erreurs
qu'on va utiliser plus tard. À ce stade, je veux m'assurer que vous, le public, savez
que vous pouvez suivre tout ce que je suis sur le point de discuter dans le tutoriel lié ci-dessous et sur la plateforme
WEBVTT
d'apprentissage IBM Quantum. Dans ce tutoriel, ce que tu remarqueras peut-être c'est qu'on a créé une série de fonctions auxiliaires
au début du notebook qu'on peut appeler plus tard pour nous faciliter un peu la vie. Je veux les mentionner
maintenant, non pas parce que ça fait partie du processus officiel ou formel, mais parce que c'est souvent ce que font les expérimentateurs
dans la vraie vie pour les aider à exécuter ces types d'expériences. Ça nous montre aussi comment on va décomposer notre
problème encore davantage. Les fonctions qu'on définit dans le notebook sont les suivantes. Remove cubit couplings.
Define cubit couplings. Construct the layer couplings. Construct entangling layers. Et enfin, define trotterized
circuit. Parlons ensuite des couplages de couches, qui aident à définir comment les qubits
interagissent avec leurs voisins pendant la simulation. Nos dispositifs quantiques utilisent ce qu'on appelle la disposition
hexagonale lourde. Un motif spécial pour connecter les qubits. Dans cette disposition, on peut regrouper les connexions appelées arêtes en trois
ensembles séparés où aucune des deux connexions dans le même ensemble ne partage un qubit. C'est
important parce que sur un vrai ordinateur quantique, on ne peut pas exécuter des gates à deux qubits en même temps si elles impliquent le
même qubit. Chaque qubit ne peut être impliqué que dans un seul gate à la fois. En
divisant toutes les connexions en trois couches, on peut appliquer des gates à deux qubits sur tout le dispositif en trois
tours, en s'assurant qu'aucun qubit n'est utilisé dans plus d'un gate par couche. Ces
gates implémentent l'interaction ZZ du modèle d'Ising, et elles sont répétées à chaque étape de la simulation appelée
l'étape de Trotter. Le twirling modifie le bruit dans le dispositif de sorte qu'un modèle de bruit simple
est susceptible d'être précis. Ça permet aussi d'apprendre avec précision le modèle de bruit et d'utiliser les informations obtenues
dans les techniques d'atténuation des erreurs.
Ensuite, on doit supprimer nos mauvais qubits de notre liste possible de qubits physiques qu'on peut utiliser pour
l'expérience. Comme je l'ai dit, un qubit peut devenir mauvais pour diverses raisons. Parfois c'est juste une mauvaise
calibration, une simple erreur qui peut être résolue en recalibrant simplement.
Parfois c'est un peu plus compliqué et lié à ce qu'on appelle un TLS, qui est un défaut interfacial à deux niveaux
qui entraîne des fluctuations et une relaxation des paramètres du qubit. Ça peut être
résolu en réchauffant un peu tout le système puis en le refroidissant à nouveau. Mais ça prend du temps et ce n'est pas possible de
faire ça via le cloud. Donc pour l'instant, la chose la plus simple à faire est de les exclure de notre liste de qubits physiques
possibles qu'on va utiliser. Tu peux facilement identifier quels qubits ne se comportent pas comme prévu depuis la plateforme IBM Quantum.
Tu peux y afficher les caractéristiques des qubits sur la plateforme ou les télécharger en CSV. Puis crée une liste de tous les
qubits que tu veux exclure et supprime-les simplement de la liste de tous les qubits physiques du dispositif.
Très bien. Continuons maintenant avec notre étape de mapping en générant notre circuit trotterisé. Comme on l'a montré
plus tôt, la trotterisation discrétise l'évolution temporelle en une série d'étapes et on doit décider combien d'étapes.
On choisira six ici. Mais en général la stratégie est d'équilibrer ce qu'on appelle l'erreur de Trotter qui est une
erreur d'approximation algorithmique avec l'erreur résultant de la décohérence. Plus d'étapes de Trotter réduit l'erreur d'approximation
mais nécessite des circuits quantiques plus profonds qui subissent plus de bruit de décohérence. On va définir le
circuit en termes du paramètre theta qui est la force du couplage de couche du champ magnétique externe et
du nombre d'étapes et de qubits et bien sûr du backend du dispositif. En raison de la
dépendance de l'aimantation du système sur la force du champ magnétique externe, il est intéressant de
exécuter la simulation à différentes valeurs de la force du champ magnétique qui se traduisent en différents angles de RX sur
la rotation pour RX dans le circuit. Maintenant qu'on a généré notre circuit, on va passer à son optimisation.
La première étape ici est de définir un pass manager. Rappelle-toi que dans le contexte du SDK Qiskit, la transpolation désigne
le processus de transformation d'un circuit d'entrée en une forme adaptée à l'exécution sur un dispositif quantique.
La transpolation se déroule typiquement en une séquence d'étapes appelées passes de transpiler. Un pass manager est un objet qui
stocke une liste de passes de transpiler et peut les exécuter sur un circuit. Crée un pass manager en initialisant un objet pass
manager avec une liste de passes de transpiler. Au final, notre pass manager
créera un circuit ISA, un circuit qui doit être écrit en termes de l'architecture d'ensemble d'instructions du backend,
qui décrit le circuit et les gates natifs au backend mais qui manque des informations de timing nécessaires pour exécuter le
circuit. On est maintenant prêts à exécuter notre circuit qui est l'étape trois des Qiskit patterns. Comme indiqué précédemment on va
certainement utiliser l'estimator comme notre primitive de choix pour cette expérience puisqu'on veut mesurer l'aimantation
totale du système et l'estimation de la valeur attendue des observables est ce pour quoi l'estimator a été
conçu. À cette étape il sera aussi crucial de spécifier nos options pour l'atténuation des erreurs. On va utiliser l'extrapolation à zéro bruit
pour obtenir les meilleurs résultats possibles. En particulier dans le tutoriel, tu verras qu'on spécifie deux valeurs ou plus
de facteurs de bruit auxquelles évaluer les modèles extrapolés et spécifier
l'amplification probabiliste des erreurs comme option d'amplification. Maintenant, l'amplification probabiliste
des erreurs ou PA était vraiment la méthode d'atténuation des erreurs de choix ici parce qu'elle s'adapte tellement mieux
que les autres options. Et c'est ce qui est important quand on travaille au niveau de 100 qubits et plus.
Enfin, exécute l'expérience et ça prendra un peu de temps à se compléter, mais pour l'instant, référençons les données
mises en file d'attente et stockées depuis le tutoriel. On va examiner les métadonnées en notant particulièrement les couches de gates et
les couches atténuées puisqu'on est sur le point d'utiliser celles-ci pour supprimer plein d'erreurs de nos données brutes. On est presque prêts
à tracer nos résultats finaux. Mais avant de faire ça, ajoutons rapidement un intermède ici sur ce que signifie exactement l'extrapolation à zéro
bruit ou ZNE. On l'a brièvement abordé dans des épisodes précédents, mais pour réviser, l'extrapolation à zéro bruit
est une technique d'atténuation des erreurs qui supprime les effets d'un bruit inconnu lors de l'exécution du circuit qui peut être
mis à l'échelle d'une manière connue. Elle suppose que les valeurs attendues évoluent avec le bruit selon une fonction connue montrée ici où les
WEBVTT
paramètres lambda spécifient la force du bruit et peuvent être amplifiés. On peut implémenter la ZNE avec les étapes suivantes.
D'abord, amplifier le bruit du circuit pour plusieurs facteurs de bruit. Lambda 1, lambda 2,
lambda 3, et ainsi de suite. Exécuter chaque circuit avec bruit amplifié pour mesurer la
valeur attendue a de lambda 1, a de lambda 2, et ainsi de suite. Puis extrapoler vers la limite zéro bruit,
la valeur attendue a de zéro.
Le principal défi pour implémenter avec succès la ZNE est d'avoir un modèle précis pour le bruit dans la valeur attendue
et d'amplifier le bruit d'une manière connue.
Il y a trois façons courantes dont l'amplification des erreurs est implémentée pour la ZNE : étirer la durée des impulsions via la calibration,
répéter les gates en cycles d'identité et ajouter du bruit via l'échantillonnage des canaux de Pauli.
On appelle ce dernier PA. L'amplification probabiliste des erreurs est le meilleur choix ici parce que l'étirement d'impulsion est très
coûteux en calcul. Le repliage de gate manque de garanties théoriques pour préserver le biais de bruit. Mais la PA peut être
appliquée à n'importe quel circuit qui peut être exécuté avec des facteurs de bruit natifs mais nécessite d'apprendre le modèle de bruit. La PA suppose
le même modèle de bruit basé sur les couches que l'annulation probabiliste des erreurs.
Cependant, elle évite l'overhead d'échantillonnage qui évolue exponentiellement avec le bruit du circuit. Pour apprendre le modèle de bruit,
on doit d'abord identifier les couches uniques d'opérations à deux qubits dans le circuit.
Pour chaque couche, twirler par Pauli les gates à deux qubits pour s'assurer que le bruit est bien décrit par un modèle de bruit d'amortissement.
Répéter les paires d'identité de couches à différentes profondeurs et enfin ajuster une fidélité ou une erreur pour chaque canal de bruit. Et
bien sûr, même si je recommande de comprendre cette méthode dans une certaine mesure, la faire à la main dans Qiskit est
beaucoup plus simple comme le montre le tutoriel. Maintenant, enfin, regardons les données tracées. La ligne
grise pointillée montre les résultats exacts obtenus avec des méthodes classiques approximatives avec une erreur d'approximation
convergeant vers un seuil bas. Comme tu peux le voir, les données brutes pour les différents facteurs de bruit qu'on a choisis au
début sont assez loin de cette ligne pointillée. La ligne bleue continue montre les données tenant compte de notre traitement ZNE
et tu peux tout de suite voir qu'elle est beaucoup plus proche des résultats exacts.
En résumé, les valeurs bruitées montrent un écart élevé par rapport aux valeurs exactes. Les
valeurs atténuées sont proches des valeurs exactes, démontrant l'utilité de la technique d'atténuation basée sur la PA.
Et ça conclut essentiellement cet épisode. Pour résumer rapidement ce qu'on a appris, la simulation quantique est l'une
des applications les plus prometteuses à court et moyen terme.
Elle a de nombreuses applications allant des médicaments à la physique des hautes énergies,
la science des matériaux et plus encore. L'article sur l'utilité d'IBM publié en 2023 a
ouvert la voie vers la capacité d'utiliser des ordinateurs quantiques pour la découverte scientifique. Et on a travaillé sur le
tutoriel associé à cet article en profondeur. Les étapes pour travailler sur un problème de simulation du début
à la fin sont relativement simples, surtout une fois que tu as pris le coup de main. Et mon espoir est que tu
puisses désormais utiliser cette vidéo et le tutoriel comme guide pour encore plus de problèmes de simulation à l'avenir.
Merci d'avoir regardé et on se verra la prochaine fois sur Quantum Computing in Practice.